sometimes you work on a production and
after you're done you just don't want to
produce anymore you know and that's how
I felt after this I said
let's say you're on day four or five of
production long hours maybe there's been
issues with location and there's someone
that you deal with or different
individuals on set whose communication
skills are maybe different maybe they're
more closed off maybe their arms are
crossed every time you go talk to them
and you can kind of pick up that there's
like this barrier especially later on in
the production how do you smoothly do
that or is it at some point it's just
going to get tense there's there you
people are going to be human and
arguments will happen
um I had this situation happen maybe
multiple times I'm thinking of one
specific situation that was very rough
you know for me I was coming off of a
feature and then I was jumping into a
short that was very aggressive and we
had high level talent and
um my producing partner you know looked
great on paper but he'd never ran a film
set and the line producer that initially
came on
ended up just walking and I don't think
it was frustration or anything because
of us or the director but he probably
found a job that paid him a lot more
um and he didn't want to do all the work
I think that's the honest truth
um so in this project I brought on a a
friend colleague of mine that's kind of
a producer I asked her to come on as
production manager and
um
I want to say I don't remember if she
didn't come at all that day or maybe she
came and just never came back to set
again
um but with this production it was a big
production we started in Central Park
and I had a financier that was coming
that had put on quite a bit of money
into the project and he wanted to come
in
take pictures on set he came with his
Entourage and at the same time I had
Talent checking in at a hotel nearby
wanted to make sure that he was okay and
the other Talent was okay
and at the same time that day the 59th
Street Bridge I think was shut down uh
so our doctor photography was running
late with the camera and our sound
person didn't come no call no show and I
have to be three places at one time I
have to be on set with my crew I have to
be with the talent to make sure they're
okay and I have to be with the financier
and the A.D couldn't really run the set
and not that he couldn't run the set but
they were not listening to him
and the reason that we got the crew that
we got which was amazing like ayatsi
crew was because of the DP
um our g e department and our camera
department and
um this was day one everything went
wrong
um I needed to get a sound person so I
found someone that had submitted from
before and they wanted double the rate
and at this point we were already
spending money so I had to bring on this
person and it was very difficult to
manage all the expectations I felt that
I was failing my team you know all
aspects in terms of the financier
wanting to be in and out and take
pictures and telling him hey we're
trying to get cameras rolling that's not
important now but I know you put this
money in so I know you need to be here
and you need you have somewhere to go
and you have all these people with you
um she was speaking with him
um and his people in a manner where they
felt respected and not disrespected and
trying to manage the crew that is like
what the hell is going on why are these
people here and we just want to work
um and then the talent expecting a level
of treatment per se
um and as the day went it just got
harder and harder there wasn't a smart
plan for the gas to get in the generator
and we fell behind schedule uh and I
probably lost a few crew members by the
end of the night
uh and it was just very horrific I know
the g e team was really frustrated they
thought I didn't know probably what I
was doing
um and they did not listen to the A.D
they only listened to the DP
um and the second day
um I promised that it would be a much
better day we had some problems on the
first day with meals and the food
getting there on time and it was just a
lot of Dynamics happening at the same
time so I did get everyone fed they did
get fed a little later
um and uh I focused on the food that
they just to make sure that the food was
really good uh top of the line and there
was an issue I want to say with one of
our main actresses because she was
playing the mother to this child and one
of the places I set up for holding
happened to be a bar near set and they
would not allow the young boy in
um and that didn't even go through my
mind it would be a problem
and she was having emotional disconnect
because that's her sons he was in
character and she would not do anything
unless I was there and I was focusing on
making sort of you know getting the food
and working with the caterer just to
make sure that the food was slamming
that day
and um I basically had to run and get
over there and you know I worked it out
and you know then she was okay and
everything was all right
um and I could just feel the energy from
the genie crew and the camera crew
um it was more probably the g e crew
that was more upset
um and I pretty much
had to do something about it because
they were I felt that I was going to
lose all of them
um or it was just going to get worse so
I asked the genie team to stop working
and to come out and speak with me they
didn't know what it was about and I had
addressed everything that happened the
day before I had explained to them which
they knew about the camera and the
bridge you know I explained to them
about the sound I explained to them
about the investor and that they had put
a good chunk of money in I had this
responsibility and you they probably
didn't care and I acknowledged that you
probably I was very honest and blunt you
guys probably don't care you just when
you do your job I understand I
understand that you all ate late
yesterday and there was uh the gas was
put in really late for the generator and
we've been behind schedule I
acknowledged everything that went wrong
I didn't ignore the pink elephant in the
room I acknowledged all of their
concerns I let them know all the
Dynamics I was facing yesterday and
basically I'm producing this whole shoot
on my own
and I literally wrapped on a feature
right before and I haven't had a chance
to take a break and again
you guys probably don't care you just
want to do your job get fed and get paid
um and I acknowledge that I will treat
them all with respect I will make sure
that they get fed on time today and that
I pretty much did not go to sleep maybe
an hour or two but I didn't go to sleep
to make sure that I have you know better
food for them because I had some people
that were vegetarian and vegan and all
these different things and
um food was delayed the day before so I
made sure that wouldn't happen and I
felt that I had to have that
conversation because they were only
there because of the DP you know and I
didn't want them to walk or lose my team
in the project fall apart because of
that
um and it was it wasn't even a question
I knew I had to have this conversation
or they would probably start maybe
disrespecting me or the set or not
listen because they weren't listening to
the first ad you know when I wasn't
there there
um so I wanted to establish like a level
of authority as well and keep it and not
lose it and also let them know that they
are humans I get that and I'm not
looking to be disrespectful to them or
the project at all
um so I feel that that's what I would do
in any situation if it happened again is
just acknowledging what they or whatever
person is going through
I'm not ignoring the problem letting
them know that I'm aware whether I can
fix it or not you know because a lot of
times people want to be heard
um and I want to make sure that they
know that I'm listening and I I do care
you know whether I can make a decision
or not sometimes I can't make a decision
you know I don't have the authority to
or it's a force outside of nature in
terms of what can or cannot be done
wow it sounds like I mean almost
everything that could have gone wrong
did
everything went wrong on that project it
was
sometimes you work on a production and
after you're done you just don't want to
produce anymore you know and that's how
I felt after this I said I don't want to
be on a film set for a very long time I
can't manage this you know it was very
stressful
um to the point where you know I lost my
drivers and I had box trucks that had to
move around with a lot of gear and
equipment and I had bonded lots that
they had to get to and I lost all my
drivers and I had to call
one of the PA's fathers really stepped
up he's a reverend he's a God-fearing
man and I think it's because you're
religious it's like why he helped and
you know also his son was a PA probably
but he was like my savior he drove the
other box truck and didn't mind and I
had to drive the box truck you know I
don't drive box trucks I don't like
driving box trucks but if I didn't do it
no one else was and we had to get this
film done you know there were a lot of
people counting on it getting done and
there was a lot at stake had to deliver